some 45,000 watch a buck graze in the
floodplains of the Gorongosa National
Park in Mozambique but that's actually
too many for the grass to sustain itself
today the animals are more jumpy than
usual and the edge of the savanna
something is afoot start from the
southern Africa conservation group P
sparks are out to get them a huge
structure with high walls will guide the
antelope into a cattle truck
as part of our rewilding process so in
total we'll move around 1,400 animals
from here and which includes water back
and will also move 200 read back this
yet the peace and quiet of the bush is
shattered as the hunt begins
[Music]
a helicopter circles groups of waterbuck
and drives them in the direction of the
truck those on the ground gets much
closer to the frightened animals when am
i Berg the head of peace parks has come
along too he spent years helping to
prepare this initiative he's making
quite a big effort across to get animals
back to a park that has been completely
wiped out of animals there's there's no
animals at all so what happened is in in
Mozambique there was a civil war it lost
over 16 years and as a result a lot of
the wildlife was decimated and to bring
back the animals you have to come to a
place like Gorongosa National Park catch
animals and then take them all the way
to new parks that are being
rehabilitated the girl goes the National
Park was one of the first in Mozambique
to be repopulated after the Civil War
ended two decades ago the effort paid
off today via even lions here and the
park had enough animals to give away
though waterbuck now begin their journey
to design a V National Park it's a 16
hour non-stop ride in the meantime staff
from peace parks already has an avi
meeting with Mozambican officials they
discuss how to develop infrastructure to
make the park more easily accessible
Bartolomeo Sotoudeh director-general of
Mozambique's national parks supports the
project there is a national strategy
that does another 15 is that we want to
rebuild all the protected area to help
the socio-economic development of
Mozambique as yet the Navi has nothing
houses are being built for the future
ranges and transferring the animals
alone will cost two point five million
dollars peace parks is children much of
the financial burden but it's also
looking for donors
[Music]
there are people living both in and
around the park
most of them impoverished farmers of
fishermen they often clear the bush for
farmland by setting fire to it
the conservationists hope to discourage
that by ensuring the park provides a new
source of employment the next day the
truck carrying the water buck finally
reaches his destination despite the long
journey the animals appear in good
condition and as soon ready to explore
the new surroundings but it's just one
step on the long road to recreate in the
natural paradise that the Navi once was
the world Tek time we think there's this
very few animals left to rebuild their
wild life bring it back to the way it
was that will take anything 15 to 20
years to really get it back to just
having reinstated the wild life as it
was before over the next few years the
waterboxx will be joined by some 7500
animals from other African parks and so
gradually the Navi will come back to
life